hello everyone and welcome to round
number five of the 1970 Palma de Majorca
inter-zonal
tournament here Bobby Fischer with the
white pieces faces Czech chess
grandmaster Miroslav Philip and Philip
was a was a really strong go grandmaster
he represented Czechoslovakia in 12
consecutive chess olympiad he won the
championship of Czechoslovakia three
times and before this game he already
faced Bobby Fischer seven times first he
faced him in the Porto ROG inter-zonal
tournament then he faced him in the
Stockholm International tournament then
they played for four games in the Cracow
candidates tournament in 1962 that's
that's where Fischer first ever defeated
him the first two times they played
together the game was drawn and then
once again in the Varna Chess Olympiad
in 1962 and this is game number eight so
in the in the seven previous encounters
five of the games were drawn and two of
the games were won by Fischer but last
time they played it was 1962 and this is
1970 so eight years have passed and
surely Miroslav Philip has gotten much
stronger in those eight years but so has
Bobby so without further ado let's check
this game out and it's this game will be
quite a treat because Fischer opens the
game with one b3 sorry about that
Fischer opens the game with one b3 so
the names of each Larson attack we have
d5 Bishop to b2 and now Knight to f6
Knight to f3 d6
and since black never really shown any
intention of developing the bf night I
usually when you go for for animal arson
attack when black develops knight c6 you
will go east extend Bishop to b5 but as
the black did no such thing
here Bobby goes to g3 he prepares for a
double fiend keto Bishop to d7 Bishop to
G - we have castles castles c5 now c4
and here Bob is basically inviting
Phillip to push the pawn to d4 close the
position but you know if if
allows this then surely Fisher is
prepared for this and if you're not
prepared for this then you're not gonna
have a lot of fun playing this so
instead a Philip goes for Knight to c6
we have a sea capture some d5 Knight
captures on d5 and now Knight to c3
Bishop to f6 by Philip and here Fischer
could go for a series of exchanges but
that doesn't really give Whitehall all
that much Knight captures Bishop
captures rook to be one pawn captures
Knight rook captures Bishop and now
after d4 all is well here for black so
after this Bishop to f6 move Queen to
see one fish were simply defends the
double pond b2 we have b6 now Knight
captures and e5 e captors on d5 and now
d4 and here Bishop to a6 by filled it
seems like Fischer is offering a free
pawn here but not really of course you
can't capture with the pawn because the
night is hanging and c6 but after Knight
captures Knight captures now you can
either exchange your bishops or or not
you can simply place T capture son d4
and you are up upon his black but it's
double the D pawn not really something
to look forward to Queen d2 Luke the one
will win the pawn easily so after d4 a
Phillip goes for Bishop to a six attacks
d2 phone but also fins it as the rook is
on f1 we have rook to e1 getting out of
the pin but also not protecting the e2
point and only now a field goes for
Knight captures on d4 we have better
capture some d4 so allowing Phillip with
the bishop pair C captures on d4 and now
Queen to a3 attacking Phillips Bishop on
a6
pushing back to b7 and here we have rook
a to d1
now you can see that but it's up upon
but again it's a double to deep one and
you're not gonna be able to defend it
Bishop to e7 attacking the Queen Queen
to a4 now with a triple attack against
the d4 pawn queen to e8 offering a queen
trade but now official declines and only
now recaptures on d4 look to see it and
now Queen to f4 and now the material on
the board is equal but you can see that
Fischer has two point islands and fill
has three point islands and Phillip has
this isolated the deep on which Fisher
will make sure that it remains a target
Bishop to f6 we have night before and
now Bishop to e5 attacking Fisher's
Queen Queen to e3 and now g6 Knights to
b5 a very nice move that really Phillip
has to decide what to do here
Fisher is offering the night if Queen
captures night then Fisher will play
Queen captures on e5 but what's the idea
if you play something like a six and
then you get a Bishop captures on d5
attacking the undefended Bishop on b7
after Bishop captures rook captures and
again you can capture the night but now
the bishop is attacked twice here so I
have to remove the Bishop simply Queen
captures rook captures and after Knight
attacks both rooks Bishop captures rook
captures and after rook to c2
you can play a4 and the back can capture
any two but you can capture on b6 so
white will remain upon up and in Fisher
had Fischer sense that this would most
likely turn into a victory
what a feel it missed here after this
night to b5 move is a very subtle idea
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find a nice move
Phillip could have played here it's not
really anything that you know changes
the course of the game it would be a
slight improvement but a move like this
might you know stick stick with you and
help you in the future so uh for those
of you who are able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
player and for those who just want to
enjoy the show
here a move that could have been played
is rook to c5 simply attack the knight
on b5 and now you're threatening d4 and
also the knight is attacked so you do
have to do something nice to d4 is the
best it blocks the D pawn and gets the
knight out of the attack if you capture
here then you lose the game then comes
d4 after we move the Queen simply
captures captures and now Queen to
eighth
check check the King and picks up the
knight on a seven by thinkings you want
Queen captures on a seven and this game
over for white so a very interesting
idea here
rook the c5 but okay in the game
one for queen capture some b-52 Fischer
played Queen captures on e5 rook F to e8
attacking Fisher's Queen Queen back to
be 2 and now rook the c5 Philip knows
that Fischer will now create an attack
against the d5 pawn so he will use the D
open C file at the double up his rooks
we have h4 by Fischer rook eat the CA
Phillip doubles up on the C file and now
rook to d2 Fischer doesn't allow Phillip
to bring his rook to c2 but also
prepares to double up on the D file rook
to c3
grabbing more space now comes a rook - d
- quinta c5 would with a triple battery
and the C file and now well Bishop
captures on d5 is definitely a
possibility you can play this grabbed
upon immediately first the Fischer wants
to get rid of any weaknesses he has in
his own camp before he captures the deep
on first before attacking the Queen
Phillip moves the Queen Queen to e7 and
now not capturing the pawn just yet but
first III getting all of his pawns on
dark squares first we have h5 by Phillip
and now comes even a three so Fisher put
all of his pawns on dark squares so none
of the points will will be filled be
able to use later as targets and only
now is he ready to capture the d5 pawn
king to h7 by Phillip and now comes the
shock captures on d5 Bishop captures
rook captures on d5 and Queen to e4 now
and Fischer plays rook to d8 rook to d8
a very nice move because it completely
immobilizes the c3 rook if you have
removed the rook let's say Roxy - seems
like a very nice active move you get
Queen h8
this is checkmate so a very nice move by
Fischer of course you don't want to
allow the exchange here
Phillip played Queen to f3 so what do
you do here King - H - it's a it's a
wonderful move by Fischer because well
at some point Fischer would definitely
like to bring his rook over to d7
threatened the f7 pawn but currently
this losses to Roxy won't check if you
move the King you get Queen to h1 or
rope to h1 checkmate so if you capture
capture capture capture you would be
down a rook so completely
winning game for black
so first after this Queen to f3 simply
King to h2 by Fischer not allowing if
this rope ever comes to see want to be
able to play this would check so we have
rook a to the c4 and now comes finally
rook 1 to d7 attacking the f7 pawn we
have g5 but now simply other route comes
to f8 with a double attack against the
f7 pawn king to g6
now comes rook to G's G a check King
moves back and now rook captures and g5
grabbing that another extra pawn and
black now has simply no counter played
that the Queen unbeatable e placed
guarding against Queen captures an f2
and also as we've said you can never
move the c3 rook because well okay now
it's not Queen nature but now Queen to
g7 will be checkmate here rope to see it
was played I feel like we brought the
Rope back and now comes route rook 7 to
d5 from Fisher King to h6 and now rook
d2 f5 and it was in this position that
Miroslav Phillip resigned in the game
the Queen is under attack there's really
no good swear for the Queen you could
play something like Queen to c6 but then
you get Queen to e2 again the threat of
Queen captures here will be checkmate
and there's no good way to defend this
you can try something like this simply
give up the Queen for no reason but
white can simply ignore you
let's say Rock f6 and after you capture
only then deliver checkmate so yeah a
wonderful game by Bobby from round five
and yet another opportunity missed by
Phillip to get at least one win against
Bobby Fischer so this is their eighth
game together and so far the score is 5
draws and and 5 wins for Bobby Fischer
so an excellent game Bobby Fischer is
currently four and a half out of five in
the Palma de Majorca inter zonal
tournament of 1970 very nice tournament
so far for him and like I said
especially for someone who didn't even
qualify through the 1969 US Championship
Series so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and I do hope you enjoy your
enjoying the series so far I think of
her watching as usual you
checked all my previous videos here
actually pre-recorded this video
yesterday I'm currently in Belgrade I
came to Belgrade to meet David Lada he's
there on business so if you're
interested in what's going on you know
feel free to follow some some of my
other social media and you know you know
keep keep in touch so I think I'll and I
will see you soon with a game number
game number seven